hey everybody I'm Rod Fergusson the
studio head at the coalition and I'm
Matt Searcy on the lead campaign
designer on Gears four and we're here to
show you the first twenty minutes of the
game so you want to tell them about why
we have a prologue sure the the prologue
was about a few things for us one of the
things we wanted to do is drop you right
in the action with the game like gears
it's really important that we get you in
there and the way our story went it was
a good idea for us to use it also as a
history lesson so we're going to take
the player back in time to some key
battles from sort of the past of the
Gears of War franchise and then one of
the other things we wanted to do is make
sure we have a mission that was well
structured for tutorials so we could
teach some core mechanics to anybody
that was returning or coming new to the
gears franchise and also we want to
introduce you to First Minister Jim
she's a character that's going to go
throughout the game and we wanted to
establish her here but so get ready for
a trip down to Asheville Point a battle
against the UI are you get to visit
house of sovereigns on e day and of
course anvil gate at the end of the
locust war so here take a look
and we're back finally today in new
ephyra First Minister Jin commemorated
the 25th anniversary of the end of the
locust war today we are humbled by the
presence of two generations of men and
women who braved every danger who fought
the battles that made us what we are
including the most pivotal encounter of
the pendulum wars Ashbaugh fields
Santiago I'll spare you the
inspirational speech rabbit you know
what to do yes sir all right let's do
this
we take down those towers [ __ ] their
communications then raid the lab man
once the hammer of dawn the man gets the
hammer of dog all right
whoa big ears we're only gonna get one
shot to expect those planet let's you
take that in comm towers his entire face
is cut off yes sir
got it is up take them out
nice shot
way to go right come on the majors
waiting
damnit they're dug in get around and
plank them
don't worry
let's go that was just a head
sleep screen one protein bonfire
Roger leg green one and sweet hell these
are domains
okay man in charge on that tower car
quieter cleaner our match is lit Roger
that
we're lighting our bonfire in three two
oh [ __ ] kid in our code name Santiago
see you at the lab yes sir the labs just
beyond that security gate pushup
machine-gun nests we're splitting up you
to take left
spotted me cover
Hey
nice
I've got through that door and don't
mind the mess you too you have the
security code override that game come on
man with that this raid is officially
underway let's go all right you know the
drill let me take the guards get inside
the lab grab the plants then we ghost so
what is this hammer gone thing do it
wins the war if we do our job right
every system here is white and the indie
scientists get an offer they can't
refuse all right we're in let's go
all right we're in time to rendezvous
with the major come on
- major butt
goddamn sir
coming from the left
keep it up
Oh
Oh
Oh
got it that's secure major have eyes
private now let's get those plans
step aside product looks like these
indie scientists aren't too eager to
meet us
Bruce be a dear and rip this door
gears listen up if we're not out in 10
minutes abort mission and get the hell
out of here
okay Santiago domina meet our new
friends
right behind you major
hold your position
indeed
here
Oh
control package is secured cleaner
proceed to the beats for Marlin extract
you hear that incoming run major to the
beach go go go get out of here stop
just that hey mommy
when Valley's law forces captioned the
new IRS plans for the hammer of dawn we
ensured our survival and the worst
conflict our world had yet known
but only two years later a new horror a
new enemy a new war control be advised
divert the Colonel's convoy their
negative negative control the house of
sovereigns is a red zone
humble can this whole cities a red zone
understood control
come on gears turtle Hoffman's convoy is
gonna need protection although ferret
control Oh
Oh
larger
come on
move up the cistern
don't work for [ __ ] on that thing
we need something bigger
soldier secure that hammer
get that hammer in hand
Oh
it's retreating nice work a monster
fight though
Hey
good job what the hell are those things
what's your name corporal Kim sir the
Jetta Strom nah need an escort
congratulations your red girl we need to
get inside now I've got the code for the
door colonel
well good for you son hold these stairs
with that hammer I'll be back when I can
oh man this is bad
all right you were the corporal's don't
let him inside coming right at us
lose the hammer
go push your back push your back he
needs no goddamn
sighs nothing near the door
what is that thing
you got another one
yo I'm sorry Aragon just went offline by
nightfall hundreds of thousands were
dead emergence day had earned its name
like many of you I was only a child then
it was a dark terrible time and our
victory was in no way assured
I know your medics that we need everyone
on that wall now get that soldier back
on the street
good all right gears get up that letter
come on Oh am I
say no you're way out down that hole
we got
pick your shot Thank You Carol
everywhere
come on don't matter love
rattling off
very
you're burning over here
alright someone about that turn throw
some hell down there
I said
you big ugly shuttle [ __ ] tell me what
you got
[Applause]
but against all odds a great group of
soldiers led by Marcus Fenix finally
ended our locust nightmare
[Music]
he did it how dearly I wish Sergeant
Phoenix could be with us here today stop
and think about the men and women in
whose sacrifices
guaranteed our survival thanks to them
we fought through the long Twilight we
built a new prosperity the world the new
cog has ensured knows no war no
suffering it's a world of safety of
family a world finally all right there
you go
that's the first 20 minutes of Gears of
War 4 it's the prologue a trip down
memory lane
yeah the prologue was really cool for us
we got to explore some places the game
has never been before like the pendulum
wars but he also got to reconnect with a
bunch of the characters from the old
games yeah it's nice to see Dom I can't
yeah and so from there you get to go on
to fighting robots to fighting monsters
the middle the night I mean it's a it's
an epic journey with JD Kayden Bell is
they they try to live and survive that
one night with a swarm now it comes out
on October 11th but if you get the
ultimate Edition you can actually get
early access and play on October 7th and
if you preorder we have a bunch of
digital exclusive sums I'm really
excited about like old man Marcus
everybody loves old man - tomorrow Anya
and of course zombie Dom Dom's back
another way another way and we have the
gold wave Lance turn the gold lead nah
sure and even a vintage Dell so there's
lots to get if you preorder and please
do and actually you know as part of our
cool things about the digital version of
our game is if you get that you actually
get cross play and to be able to get it
on console you get it on Windows 10 they
can play together in the co-op mode so
it's there's a lot of great reasons to
order digitally so hopefully we'll see
you online October 11th and hey Ultimate
Edition October 7th see you then
you
[Music]